[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster
i'm constantine kitchen and this is a
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people
we have two brilliant guests for you
today emma webb
commentator and ella whelan uh
journalist commentator and author of
what women want
fun freedom and an enter feminism there
we go i got that all right uh
not the first time i'll be honest
welcome both hi
it's good to have you back and emma
we've been meaning to have you on the
show for a long time
uh not necessarily the best
circumstances to
to have you on the show there's been
some tragic events and uh that was one
of the reasons we
wanted to have you on the show the
abduction and murder of a woman here in
london
our international audience may not be
familiar with it and the conversation
that is ensued from that vigils protests
policing we'll get into all of that but
we wanted to talk about the broader
issue
of women's safety first and foremost uh
and it's this thing that you know it's
two guys in particular when we talk to
women in our lives who may be
not feminists or not you know almost
every woman has some experience of being
harassed
being followed being mistreated in some
way
what is what is the situation in terms
of women's safety in
2021 emma uh well i so i personally
as you say you know most women have at
some point walked home with their keys
between their fingers at night or
um had someone harass them in the
streets but usually the person
who in my experience is you know a nut
case could be a woman could be a man
um i think that the women's obviously
women's safety
is something important and we should
talk about it but i think
the way that we have been talking about
it since the murder of sarah everard
is just completely off the wall and
unrelated and
to do with many other things other than
the actual murder itself
um so yeah i think it's not an issue
necessarily to do with
sort of men particularly it's not uh
as people have been calling it an
epidemic of misogyny it's not
systemic misogyny um i think that
you know women's safety is something
definitely worth discussing but the
hysterical overreaction to um the sarah
everard case
that case is quite unusual um
in the scheme of the sorts of uh like
homicides against women
people have been calling them femicides
um usually tend to happen
from someone that the woman knows and uh
women are less likely to be
murdered in public than in the public
space than men
so i think those are two very separate
issues and
they're all of these different things to
do with everything from catcalling to
murder and kidnap have just been
clumped together recently so i think
there's a there's an awful lot to unpick
what's your take on it i mean it is a
complicated picture and i think you have
to be honest and brave enough to say
that it's a complicated picture and
there are many people today who
want just want to package it up very
neatly whether that be saying there's no
problem
this is a hysteria or saying like emma
says that you know
femicide is on the rage and we all
should you know we should entertain
ideas like curfews
i mean the fact is girls are told from a
young age by their parents
in particular in a different way that
boys are told to be careful on the way
home
you know my parents told me to
think about what i was wearing not from
not because they had some kind of
misogynistic view of controlling women
but
you know out of a sense of safety and
care
and you you know most women do and all
the women i know anyway
have experiences of not necessarily
being assaulted
but having your heart rate quicken of
thinking you know thinking twice about
taking
the quicker route home which is darker
or the longer route home which is a long
main road
all that is a truth and it happens but
at the same time
you have to acknowledge as emir says
that statistically the likelihood of any
of us ending up
like sarah everard you know which is our
worst nightmare to end up like that
um is incredibly low so of 1500 women
that were murdered in the last
uh 10 years between 2009 2018 by men
it was about eight percent of them were
murdered by strangers through kidnapping
or you know someone on the street
attacking them
so that's a really small percentage so
that so the likelihood
of one of us going out on the street and
being attacked like sarah
is statistically incredibly low but that
doesn't quite answer
the question of why women are feeling
afraid and for me
the concept of safety isn't just about
what is the physical threat that you
that might happen to you but it's also
about how do you feel yourself how
confident are you
and the tragedy the continuing tragedy
of what happened to sarah
is that what or what i think a lot of
contemporary feminists are now
have kind of given into is the idea that
women should feel
deeply terrified that actually that
their fears their greatest nightmares of
ending
up like sarah everard are reality and
what that really is doing
is you know giving into the mo of men
that want to hurt women is that allowing
is kind of asking women to live in fear
which is what these men want they want
women to be
afraid that's why they commit these
crimes it's not just it's not just
coincidence they don't just do it for
the hell of it they do
you know most of them do it to make
women feel afraid and so
you know safety it's you know
statistically you are going to be very
safe on the street and
as much as most women are afraid also
most women fall home out of clubs and
walk home on their own and
you know i can imagine numerous
situations that i put myself in as a
teenager that would make me wince now
but i did it without a thought when i
was younger
because that's you know you you live
freely when you're young
but the question is you know what's what
is better to compound women's fears that
are
in some cases irrational or to say
actually we want to
reclaim the streets we want to you know
reclaim the night
and be as comfortable on a public sphere
as a man is from 3pm to 3am i take i
think
the latter is far more progressive than
the former and why do you think
this the murder of this of sarah everard
sparked this particular movement why do
you think was it was it lockdown
was it because it was a police officer
who's been who's been charged with this
crime although he hasn't been convicted
as of yet
well i was thinking about it in relation
to the murder of george floyd you know
in
a similar situation in which there is a
long-standing problem with police
brutality and racism in america and
george floyd is certainly not the first
black man to die at the hands of a
police officer
why did it particularly take off in
relation to him and why was there such
mass movements
with black lives matter why has sarah
everard hit cord
and i think because we you know it's
it's a tricky point to make but i think
politically we've
moved further into a realm of extremes
which is not to get kind of wishy-washy
liberal about it but to say that
you know you immediately that people
have a kind of knee-jerk reaction that
they immediately
jump to the kind of worst-case scenario
so we're not even talking about sexism
we're talking about misogyny at the
moment that there's a you know that
we've have people on the radio saying
the police are institutionally
misogynistic you think okay i'm not a
fan of the police
but the police institutionally hate
women i mean misogyny is about
a deep-seated visceral and violent
hatred
of women no there's no evidence of that
in the sense
it's very similar with the kind of the
idea of white privilege that came out of
those black lives matters movement in
the wake of george floyd's murder
the idea that all white people you know
have a kind of
innate violence within them that just
exists as an abstract thing
we've now got this sort of conversation
that all men no matter
what their sensibilities or their
behavior or their track record or
their beliefs have an innate violence
within them
that exists abstract to their individual
individuality
that poses a threat to women and you
know
at the same time i'm also not surprised
that it's kicked off because
in the past we've had of course the
metoo movement we've also had everyday
sexism which was laura bates pet project
and has kept her in columns and books
for years which is the i you know
the idea that we women live under
everyday sexism and live under fear
the kind of hollow back movement which
was about reclaiming the streets
there's been so many different kind of
hashtags and you know and campaigns
um around women's safety that i it
again this is kind of a sore point but
it can feel like
there are lots of people who've been
campaigning around this issue
for a long time and now they kind of
have their
they have their evidence of you know one
murder but it's a terrible murder they
have their evidence to say
look look at what happened to sarah
edward we told you that there is an
epidemic of femicide
and of course most sensible people can
see that that's not the case
see it's it's it's difficult for us
because
we hear what you guys are saying you
know obviously take it on board but
as i said if you speak to if we speak to
women in our lives that's definitely a
part of their lives that they have to
deal with right and you i think you
speak to any woman
that is a concern then again the
statistics are men are much more likely
to be assaulted in public in the street
than women
so like how do we even have this
conversation
yeah i think cynically i'm very cynical
about this i agree totally with
everything that you've just said i think
that
the way that um
obviously we can talk about how the
protests and things have been
have been hijacked but obviously in the
same way that happened with george floyd
where
after that there were certain people who
wanted us to see systemic racism
everywhere
now there are some people who want us to
see systemic misogyny everywhere
and so you have people like baroness
jenny jones immediately coming out and
saying the solution to this problem
is that we just should lock all men
inside after 6 p.m put a curfew on them
because
that essentially implies that there is
like you say something
you know inherent to men inherently
violent which i think
doesn't chime at all with women's
experience so when it comes to having a
having conversations between men and
women and just in the public space about
this i feel like
this has really has no bearing on
people's real
uh experience with women's experiences
of these things
and also men as you know husbands
fathers
brothers um i think that the way that as
you mentioned
um my everyday sexism boris johnson
coming out and saying that you know
everyday sexism is something that's you
know we have to figure out the root of
it and that's why
we need to deal with misogyny in society
and sorry just a thought about boris
johnson talking about everyday
sexism i just we've managed to we've
managed to make the debate about
something completely unrelated to the
starting point and that's the same as
what happened with george floyd
and i think cynically the reason why
this is the case is because
we have these ideas in the zeitgeist
that are sort of
um whirring around and
with any and as i mentioned because they
believe in
systemic racism or systemic sexism
they will see that everywhere and it
creates this kind of panic and when you
have a
a situation where policymakers
are responding in a knee-jerk way to
that kind of panic not only can you not
have a proper discussion about it
but you also end up with ridiculous
policies that are
built on the hysteria that has been
which it has no no real um sensible
reasonable relation to the actual facts
well you talk about the proper
conversation this is what i'm trying to
work out because that's
what the purpose of of us for being
together what is the reasonable
conversation did we all just go well
look
the reality of life is people get
murdered people get assaulted
you know we can try and you know tinker
with the criminal justice system but
that's about all we can do and some
people are always gonna you know be the
victims of that and that's terrible but
this
is is that the reason do you know
because it feels
like we're slightly you know that's not
i don't know maybe that's true but it's
like we're not doing enough
that that would be the argument some
people might make well i mean you know
the the
it's true to say that more men are
subject to violence
um particularly in the public's fat
square um than women but of course
context is key so you know it's
men committing violence against other
men and you know the abstract from the
whole thing
uh separate from it is that women don't
go around battering people
you know generally some do but generally
women don't go around committing crimes
of violence against men
or against other women in the same in
the same kind of statistics as men do
so context is key i mean you know two
guys brawling outside a pub is very
different from
the case of sarah everard you know that
that context is key in this and i think
we
discussions tend to lose that i want to
live in a world in which we
change the rate of rate we change the
rate of
murder against women i mean in
particular this part the frustrating
thing is that
if you really want to have a serious
conversation about the instances in
which women are in danger of murder i
mean domestic abuse is the
main one and you can pass all the laws
you like that we know that the problem
with domestic abuse is that police
officers don't take
certain cases as seriously when women
initially report that they are having
problems with an ex-partner
so you know implementing a new law and
put making misogyny a hate crime doesn't
change that fact
and there's this kind of weird sort of
double thinking going on where on the
one hand you have contemporary feminists
saying the police are discussing they're
institutionally sexist they're
misogynist they're awful
but by the way we want to have loads of
them in the bar with us we want to have
them on the street watching us when
we're walking about in case
it's a hate crime and we'd really like
to have one on every street corner and
you think well which one is it are these
guys
evil or are they your saviors but at the
same time
you know this is it's an uncomfortable
conversation to have because
the reality is that women experience
life different to men
and you know in many cases and there are
lots of people who disagree with me on
that and there's some people who
i think have a have a real visceral
reaction to men being portrayed as
or as you know heinous and awful which
is the right reaction to have because
they're not
and there are some people that want to
say for god's sake this isn't a problem
let's stop the hysteria
but look sexism didn't just come about
like drop from the sky
historically it was about women being
judged to be lesser than men
you know more in need of protection more
fragile
and less capable of dealing with
hardship that is that was the root of
sexism that's why women weren't allowed
to work that's why women weren't allowed
to vote
um the the problem is those tendencies
haven't really been challenged in the
modern era despite laws being
implemented in fact they've actually
been turned on their head and now more
often than not it's contemporary
feminists arguing that
either women need chaperones which they
you know they have done in the wake of
me too i remember david schwimmer
getting praised for saying that he'd
invite a chaperone
when a female interviewer would and
would interview him
i mean that's like straight out of the
victorian playbook or that
that we need more police intervention i
mean to take a really specific thing
you know what i've talked about this on
the trigonometry before and in the past
you know some of us who are interested
in women's freedom are currently trying
to get
abortion decriminalized which is making
a position which is stating a position
that says
the state should have no say in women's
private lives and then
these you know other feminists come
along and say actually we want misogyny
criminalize
we want the state invited into our lives
we want to have police involved in our
everyday decisions we want to have
authorities involved in the way in which
we make choices about
um about how we live and you just think
you're ruining
you're ruining all the progress that was
ever made in the past about women
becoming independent
and i think that you know the there is
the problem
that women have a different role in
society to men that we said there are
still vestiges
of sexism in some areas whether it be in
relation to child rearing or indeed
relation to bodily autonomy
and you're compounding that sexism by
suggesting that we are
victims uh for men victims at the hands
of men
that is what they said in 1910 that is
what they said in the 1800s to stop us
from entering public life and it's just
being reconstituted
and you know slap a bit of glitter on it
and put a press statement out from the
faucet society and
i'm meant to eat it up and it's just
it's sickening actually but
don't you think as well and maybe it's
me being slightly conspiratorial about
this but don't you think that we've
just become there's a creeping desire
for authoritarianism
in a lot of people we've seen it in
lockdowns and you see
here they just go we should have a
policeman in every bar
in every nightclub and i'm like you know
my mother grew up in venezuela that's
what they have there that's not a good
thing
yeah i mean in particular sorry in
particular
the undercover cops thing i mean on
andrew marr um the weekend after the
the um news of sarah everard's death
came about jess phillips labour mp was
on and she was talking about the fact
that you know she said
something like there are so i go out and
i see so many wardens giving parking
tickets you know to cars
and i think why can't there be the same
level of attention giving to women so
you think
one parking ticket attendant
so universally accepted as one of life's
greatest menaces
is really not a good example but also
you know the
the idea that i would want more men
watching me because most police officers
are men or that we've just had the
scandal with the spy cops of police
officers being revealed to have not only
had sex with women in the green in the
environmentalist movement but families
with them undercover cops it's been a
huge scandal
and so now you want to put stick these
undercover bastards
will a woman ever be allowed to sneak
off to the smoking area to
kiss someone that she hasn't met before
without someone looking around the
corner
i mean it's disgusting i've just got
this image of coming out of a
bar or someone and policemen go excuse
me if you left your girlfriend outside
there's a ticket on her or something
yeah treat women like cars great ideas
hey constantin do you love trigonometry
of course
incredible interviews hilarious live
streams
hard hitting satire plus my handsome
jawline
whatever takes away from your hairline
but if you do love trigonometry and you
want to support us
there's only one place to do that and
that's on locals
yes locals is a brilliant platform that
has been incredibly supportive to
our show and other problematic creators
the great thing about locals is that
it's a community for people
who love trigonometry that's right it's
a place for you to hang out with
like-minded people
share thoughts memes and discuss the
show you can enjoy it for
free but it also gives you the option of
supporting us
for as little as seven dollars a month
and if you want to give more
you can we have incredible rewards for
our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group course and one on two chats with
me and kcat get
in join our community by hitting the
link in the description
and the pin comment below see you there
guys
this conversation was not problematic
enough let's let's take it up a notch
which is this whole conversation about
not all men which is essentially i think
people some people quite reasonably go
well look educating me about not raping
people isn't going to reduce the number
of rapes in the country because i'm not
a rapist
right do you know what i mean yeah so
how do we have that conversation without
looking like a dick basically is what
i'm trying to get
i don't think it's easy to have that
conversation all without getting in
trouble particularly as a man
but i do think that it's it's
obviously the people who are going to
commit the crimes like
the guy who potentially we don't know
because it has he hasn't been convicted
of anything yet the guy who
cop met who may have murdered sarah
everard um
you know people like that are going to
commit crimes no matter what you do you
can pass legislation and you can
try to deal with people who are
catcalling and wolf whistling and you
can clamp down on people's
freedom of speech and destroy the
relationships between the sexes
in the process of trying to do that and
to as we've seen in so many other areas
of hate crime
raise the temperature so that everybody
feels increasingly restricted which is
quite ironic because
they're talking about like the over
policing of the protests but at the same
time they also want to over legislate
in areas like that i think that that is
a bit of a weird um
double standard that they've got going
on there but i do think that you know
it's
it's pretty much an eye on impossible
for a straight
man to talk about this subject because
you've already been demonized
as we saw with the you know you need to
be locked inside after
six o'clock it's there's not really
anything that you can say because it
will be
viewed in that particular framework
that's already being promoted
so yeah i think one of the reasons why
it's important for us to
see things in a slightly more
complicated way and there is no nuance
in the debate we need to move away from
that
the understanding of these things as
being systemic
so that you guys can have a voice and we
can have a reasonable discussion and we
can talk about
you know the wives and brothers and um
you know who who care very much about
women and who are
not shouldn't be talked about as if they
are somehow complicit in the crimes
of a very very small minority of men who
would commit those crimes
regardless of what you do about misogyny
in society it's also a complete
misunderstanding of what is happening
when
someone like the alleged murder of sarah
everyone commits those crimes
or when someone rapes a woman there's
particularly in relation to rape there's
been this sort of
real blaring of the specificity of his
in terms of consent classes and things
like that people now see rape as just
this thing that someone
happens to kind of fall into because
they're not educated about i mean it's
that's it's perverse it's not you don't
have to kind of
get into the graphic ins and outs of
what happens in rape but if the person
who's doing it knows what they're doing
is wrong
either that or that everyone is
completely inebriated and it's still
wrong so it's you know it's
it's quite clear to know when when you
are committing immoral acts
and the idea of putting as emma says you
know everyone through a consent class as
if it's
as if it's like kind of health and
safety training and you just need to
know
not to step over the red line i mean
it's just it's it's a real dumbing down
of actually human relationships and what
is involved in that
but also you know to the kind of not all
men thing
i mean look if i'm walking home you know
from white chapel late at night and i
hear a footstep behind me that's too
close
i'm not going to say to myself he's
probably just an accountant he's got two
kids and everything i'm probably going
to think
oh who's that but then you know you that
that's the instinctual reaction
and taking personal responsibility yeah
which is a good thing yeah but it
and you know that's that's the
instinctual reaction and we can talk
about that we have talked about the
rights and wrongs of women feeling
afraid sometimes
without necessity sometimes but but
politically that's different so when
you're on your
own in an individual we feel all kinds
of things because
we're subjective we're emotional beings
some people like me
are able to you know wear steel toe caps
and kick people that get in our way
some people are not and i would never do
that
i would never demonize or put
shame on a woman who was afraid or timid
or anything like that but
politically when you are talking about a
collective response to something
that's outside of our subjective opinion
you have to take a firmer stance
and so you kind of get called it's like
you're an [ __ ] now if you say
we should start standing up for
ourselves i mean this is what
you know i wrote about this recently in
the 70s when peter sutcliffe was
you know routinely murdering and raping
women yorkshire ripper
and i mean talk about terror when there
was that you know particularly
in leeds and you know the towns and
areas around that
women were absolutely terrified rightly
so the police were useless the police
were not only saying that all women
should say inside they were saying that
the women who
had been murdered who were prostitutes
were asking for it because they were
prostitutes some of them not all of them
and the feminists at that time came out
and said
we're going to reclaim the night and we
and you're going to get out of our way
or we're going to trample on you and it
was a real
assertion of i have lots of problems
with feminism throughout the ages but in
particular that assertion of women's
freedom
was one of the most inspiring things
because it was about saying
whatever we are individually
collectively we are strong and that's
where men come in because
if i am in trouble on the tube or
somewhere where
where i can't you know physically as a
woman i can't battle this this threat to
me
i want to know that other members of
society are willing to step in
for me you know big woman big man
doesn't matter but
what in driving these wedges between the
sectors what we're actually breaking is
social solidarity
which is you know in a different
conversation we could talk about the
dystopian fact that anytime a crime
happens now everyone takes out their
bloody phone and films rather than
getting stuck in and it's that similar
drive to be isolated from
anatomised from each other that this
kind of discussion about men
means i want men to feel empowered to
you know feel free to interact with me
to come on to me to flirt with me
and also to step in and save me
sometimes to be free individuals who
look out for each other
and if you're telling demonizing men and
saying you know
tim stanley said this on the politics
live the other day and the bbc you know
actually he said i think men have an
innate kind of
violence inside us i mean what does that
mean women have an innate do i have an
innate weakness
yeah exactly it's like he was saying
earlier it's basically creating this
culture of
like fragility that women you know we're
not big girls and we can't look after
ourselves
which is just not healthy it's the
absolute opposite to empowerment it's me
it's telling women that they are the
victim
and if you believe in systemic sexism
then you believe that so long as men
exist women will be the victim
and the only way to to change that is to
change the law is to have the state
intervene to try and liberate you
from this like inherent masculine
violence and it just
it's a kind of um like he was saying
about george
george floyd earlier it's a kind of
mythology that we have
that we've created a kind of
post-modernist mythology that is
seeping into every area of life and you
know we saw this with the
um protest movements in response to
sarah everard that they
latched themselves on whether
consciously or unconsciously onto this
cause and like with the
misogyny bill that um the misogyny
amendment that has been um
discussed in parliament recently that
bill doesn't actually mention women
it doesn't mention women or misogynist
being referred to as a misogyny
amendment
and the government said that they're
going to get the police to start
recording misogyny as
a hate crime um but the bill itself
doesn't actually mention women it
mentions sex and gender
and it's the same as with the maternity
bill recently didn't mention motherhood
so at the same time as we're having
these conversations about misogyny
we're disempowering women and erasing
them and so you have people who are
protesting
ostensibly for women's rights in
response to the sarah everard case
whilst at exactly the same time
diminishing women's sex based rights
uh it's just completely the math yeah
but don't you think part of the problem
is is that we've stopped having good
faith conversations
and totally and you can really see that
by the solutions that come out of it
and every solution to this particular
issue has been terrible
and that's just a reflection of the
conversation we're having well i mean
the journey jones suggestion of a curfew
she initially made flippantly as a chick
as a kind of a joke yeah and then
drakeford was like yeah within
within hours mark drakeford decides this
is his moment to kind of virtue signal
and then it hits the papers and then
it's and then it becomes and then she
kind of doubles down and writes this
article saying
the response to it tells you what you
need to know about sexism in the world
and you know how disgusting that people
laugh at this idea
and suddenly it becomes reality and it's
only if
you kind of are not laughing about it i
mean despite the ridiculousness of
having a curfew and lockdown
anyway it's like no one thought of that
but suddenly this thing that was a joke
and was flippant is now potentially
going to be made law i mean the thing
about the misogyny amendment
is that it's not that you know if there
was this tussling with it and claire fox
makes a great
point about this that there was tussling
with it about whether it was going to be
part of the domestic abuse but it's
going through the house of lords at the
moment
whether or not it was going to be part
of the police the ant you know the
police crackdown bill
that you know pretty patel's brainchild
um or whether it was going to be its own
law and basically what's happened is
there's been maneuverings in
behind the scene stellar creases had a
word in some ministers here there's been
some
handshake and across the parties and the
minister now has
assured the house of laws that they
don't need to talk about this amendment
and socially amendment because what's
going to happen is they're going to roll
out the government is going to roll out
the program that happened in
nottinghamshire to make misogyny hate
crime
so that's it it's done it's done and it
doesn't matter how much you or i
say criticize it it doesn't matter what
how we feel about
it meaning even the undercover cops in
um
bars i mean it's probably been happening
for years and the government can now
just come out and say that that's what
they've been doing for years
but that was that was government saying
we're going to throw funding
at a particular position to put cops in
bars
you think when did you consult me about
that when you know these
they're able to justify in the same way
that they justify the cove of measures
because they say it's an emergency we
have an epidemic of misogyny we must act
now
and if people start saying you know we
have to do something
someone will be like well here's
something yeah okay we'll do that it's
not a good idea and it's not gonna fix
the problem but sure we'll do that so
dee can't put out a tweet saying you
know
this is amazing we're going to have save
the streets for women and someone a
young female black commentator and
commented underneath her saying are you
going to do something about misogynoir
which is misogynoir is misogyny
particularly against
black women and then i saw someone else
tweet saying well aren't we going to
make hate
uh miss andre a hate crime and hate
against men
but this is the logical this is what
happens anyone who has a gripe
i mean when i was at school loads of
people used to make fun of the color of
my hair and called me copper knob and
stuff you know
whatever the female equivalent of that
and um but
you know and i could have said that was
damaging to me and i wanted to be made a
hate crime because the whole thing about
hate crimes
but the whole thing about hate crime is
and they admit this themselves
it's based on the perception of hate
from the victim
right so if i get boxed in the face by a
man and i think that it's because he
hates women
rather than then he hates what i was
wearing or whatever it is
then it gets registered as a hate crime
but that's no accurate way of
understanding whether or not he
actually does hate women i mean just
because someone shouts [ __ ] does that
mean that they hate women or is there
something more complicated going on here
so in terms of we're told that it's this
like means of
accruing accurate data uh about misogyny
i mean
can't a police officer fill out freaking
form of that without passing a law
are you into thought crime territory
because you're trying to work out what
the person thought
when they committed the crime from the
perspective of the victim right and even
if and even if it's not on the like
lighter end of it where it's just
speech being restricted if it is trying
to ascertain the motive of a person who
has committed a crime
in itself like kidnapping somebody or
domestic violence
and then you ascribe a misogynist motive
to that
on the basis of someone's perception
that can't
you can't prove that objectively because
as you say it's entirely based on
perception
and it's base and it's the definition of
hostility which is just
ill feeling towards you know to be
hostile to something in
the way that you would understand it in
a normal conversation rather than any
kind of like restricted legal sense
and so then you end up with the police
essentially sort of prying into men's
souls
which ends up going down the orwellian
thought crime that sounds great
but uh guys i wanted to go back a little
bit we've got into the legal side of
which which is very interesting
um but i just wanted to come back to one
thing because i feel there's one thing
that we're not actually talking about
that maybe is true which is
you know ella you you talked about the
fact that
well if you say that men are more
aggressive than this and then
that make that means the women are the
opposite of that
but isn't it true isn't it true that you
know guys are more aggressive guys are
stronger guys are more likely to commit
crime
and therefore women are more vulnerable
to that because they're
on average smaller and and weaker and
all of that like we're not accounting
for that in this conversation are we
well i'd always reject any kind of move
towards
seeing things in a kind of biologically
deterministic way because i think that
while it is
obviously the case although i say
obviously i rejected it but it's true
no obviously i was just i was laughing
because actually now the question of sex
you know biological sex difference has
been called into question but completely
different
culture yes we've covered that pretty
well as you know but that
you know it's obviously the case that
most women are physically
less able to hold their own in a fight
than men um but that doesn't i think
that you know
natural instincts i'm much more i think
i'm much more subject to context
environment so i'm
i'm you know much more of the kind of
philosophical view that people make
decisions because of the situation that
they're in and because of the context
that they live in and the circumstances
they find themselves in understand great
marks quote
um but but you know how do you do if you
take
ideas of you know what's macho or
masculine or feminine
um there are you know this is the whole
thing of kind of criminalizing
making problematic toxic masculinity
because there are some good things about
being aggressive
and you know aggress aggression can be a
driver of progress
hate can be a driver of progress as well
actually politically particularly
um but then also there are things you
know femininity gets just passed off as
this kind of
you know wishy-washy fainting couch kind
of um scenario but obviously you know
there are different conversations about
women being much more emotionally
intelligent than men and definitely and
actually
as i say many times i would far rather
sit on the top deck of a bus with a
bunch of teenage boys at the back than i
would with a bunch of teenage girls at
the backs teenage girls can be mean
really mean and they can you know
they're actually far smarter far quicker
um than boys and so i think we get into
these thick we kind of
get into the woods about what people
naturally are like rather than actually
celebrating
this this kind of tells you where we're
at politically today rather than
celebrating the
concept of agency which is about saying
it actually doesn't matter what i am
innately that
because i can use my rational agency and
my mind and my
and my decision-making capabilities i
can override my nature so
my you know that my nature might be to
run
um when i'm in danger but i can override
that and make decisions about what i'm
going to do in that situation
and of course you know i i just
categorically deny
and and and reject the idea that men are
and innately
you know that there's some kind of
predator instinct to make them want to
um be violent against women i just don't
think there's proof of that and i think
it's nonsense it's like treating uh
people like monkeys but there but
whatever kind of
you know instincts that we have that we
either pick up from the environment or
nature or nurture
we should be championing the fact that
people have the confidence to use their
rational capabilities to make decisions
that sometimes break from the norm which
is why
you know yes the the kind of explanation
for sexism in the past was that women
were
less able for contemporary life because
we were more fragile
but of course we've said whether or not
that is true and i'm sure you could have
a
brilliant debate with biological
determinants about that i don't care
i'm going i don't care you're not going
to get to close those doors for me on
the basis of that
so it's pushing forward the idea of
agency which has
saw been kind of sorely lost in the
contemporary discussion emma what do you
think about this because
i wasn't suggesting that men are more
likely by nature to be violent against
women
but men are more likely to be violent
than women well
it's a hormonal thing isn't it
testosterone but
what we never talk about when we talk
about masculinity is virtue and
character
so we'll talk about masculinity and
toxic masculinity and about
men's strength as if it's somehow
inherently a danger not just to women
but to
everyone around them um but we never
talk about the way that that
strength and masculinity and the sort of
trappings of being biologically male
uh can be a good thing the fact that you
know my male friends often walk me
at home or walk me to the station
because probably they can better protect
me
you pointed at me because i really can't
fight
and so people you know will often walk
me home because
um you know they can use their strengths
to protect
um and that's a very traditional way of
looking at things um but i think you're
right about the agency point
um i i do think though that it's um
it's important not to talk about people
as groups full stop so talking about
you know obviously you can make
generalizations about groups of people
but if you're making unmitigated
negative generalizations
not just about a group of people but
about something to do with them that
you know that is completely immutable
like a man's masculinity or
um as we saw with the black lives matter
um
protests about whiteness and trying to
find whiteness in in everything
um because i think when you think like
this you start seeing it everywhere
and the effects that that has other than
denying people agency and actually in a
strange way
almost denying criminals of their moral
responsibility because you say well you
know they did it because they
they had this violence in them because
they're male which is just completely
absurd when you think about it in that
sense um
i think that you know that
to deny people their agency but at the
same time
you know i think that seeing these
things everywhere
in society is bad for the people who are
told that they're fragile who are told
that they are somehow you know weak in
relation
to that so um yeah
i mean it's not not to get all kind of
judith butler about it but
there is please
you know there is there is biological
reality in terms of the physicality of
our existence
but then i do i was staying away from
saying explicitly but i do
you know i am open to the conversations
about the fact that gender is in many
ways
a construct to to go to the down the
judicial right but
that you know their their their cousins
is part of the interesting thing about
us
and the women's role is different today
than it was 20 years ago than it was
120 years ago and the same with men i
mean we talk about the
you know men have changed over the last
sort of 30 40 years
drastically i mean my father's
generation is completely different to my
husband's generation now
you know there will be some places
particularly among you know working
class guys who've been doing for example
the same jobs
for years where the behavior is
relatively the same and people still
have those kind of very positive
masculine
which actually as it happens women can
adopt as well i
tend to go down the matcha route too
often more often than i should
but that you know actually men have
changed they've become more open to
their feelings which a lot of the time
kind of
makes me sick because there's a you know
there's the whole
facialization of being open with each
other and i tend to think people should
shut up more than they do
but but we are you know we react to the
world in which we live in
and if you really believe that we are
hemmed in by the
by the trappings of our physical
existence then what's the hell of what
is the point of politics what's the
point of
any belief in any kind of change we are
malleable
you know uh creatures we can we outside
of us and shape ourselves in the process
and so denying that flexibility by
saying that
men are innately and have always been
the enemy and women are
always the you know the damsel in
distress
just you know give up go home don't ever
engage in public life ever again because
what's the point
i'm sorry francis i don't disagree with
ella but she'll knock me out go ahead
do you watch problematic content online
of course they do they watch
trigonometry
many isps log your internet activity
and sell that data on to other big tech
companies
or other advertising companies i know
that is why
i use expressvpn to hide my browsing
activities
i bet you do expressvpn is a simple app
which you can have on both your computer
and your smartphone
which hides your traffic into one
channel and directs it through
a vpn server which means your isp can't
see anything that you're doing look the
question
i want to ask no will it slow down the
videos that i watch
definitely not that is one of the
reasons it's been rated as the number
one vpn app by cnet
and wyatt i don't read those
publications because i'm not a nerd
stop handing over your personal data to
isps and big tech companies which are
just going to use it and sell it on
visit expressvpn.com
trigger that's e x p r
e s s v p n
dot com slash trigger i love it when you
spell things out but it gets even better
than that
expressvpn are offering trigonometry
fans three
extra months free go to expressvpn.com
trigger to learn more the problem
the fact that we've all just lost our
minds over lockdown
so we've stopped being able to have a
rationing conversation because we've all
gone mad and i include myself in that
well i mean yeah the the atomization
look she gave you was brilliant without
any comment on the state of your mental
well-being
i think i think that part of the trend
of lockdown to be
you know in in a previous lifetime
before we ever talked about coronavirus
i'd be very critical of people that said
that you know
being online all the time on your own
affects you that you become more of a
kind of keyboard warrior or that kind of
thing
i'd say oh people are more intelligent
than that and i still think people are
more intelligent that but
we've had a mandated a mandated
isolation for a year now
and you know i've just waxed little
lyrical about what kind of malleable
creatures human beings are we're also
social creatures
and when you end up being in isolation
for too long you lose perspective it's
this
it's you know it's a similar thing that
politicians who stay in london too long
have no idea what the lies are like of
people in wakefield it's the same thing
if you're in your four walls for too
long and you don't know what life is
like for your neighbor you don't you
don't have conversations with people
i mean you know that i work with the
academy of ideas and we do the back of
ideas festival that was cancelled last
year but it is on this year thank god
um and part of the part of the
importance of public events like that of
actually rubbing shoulders with someone
physically
with being in the same room with someone
is that you pick up
on on you intuit things and you know
especially in relation to
personal relationships between the sexes
so much more happens in our
understanding of each other
between the lines of what's not said so
i can say to you you
know um you know a man came up to me
yesterday and he
and he said to me hello beautiful and
you could think oh that's a lovely thing
you know and that could be a really
wonderful experience and i could have
really enjoyed that
or if we but if he was saying it to me
that close to my face then it would be a
completely different context it'd be a
completely different feeling
and if we aren't actually sort of not to
fetishize
kind of physical interaction but if
we're not actually in a
in the public space in the public sphere
interacting with each other
all of that nuance and context gets lost
and that's why you said
why are we kind of jumping to extremes
of passing laws
it's because all of these politicians
that are pushing for these laws are
doing it on zoom they're not even like
you know
so it's it's ridiculous yeah i can't i
can't remember where i'm stealing this
from but
um someone said that um does the thing
that
reigns in people with an authoritarian
instinct is that they'll be sitting like
a revolutionary
in their in their room and then they'll
go downstairs and they'll speak to the
shopkeeper and they'll have an exchange
and that simple interaction of
negotiation where they realize that the
shopkeeper isn't this horrible
capitalist enemy but is just a nice
neighbor that you
you know interact with every day that
that makes a big difference it actually
i think that
um and like you said not to fetishize
interaction but i think that
actually seeing people in the flesh
forces us into a nuance that we were
already not inclined towards it was the
like the last bastion of that was the
last
resource we had for giving us that
nuance and then as soon as we were shut
inside
all of these ideas these slightly
authoritarian instincts that were
bubbling away underneath the surface
just immediately got their claws into
everyone's brain
and so any opportunity then to actually
get out
of the house for the last year really
has been protesting
to go out with other people who are
hyped up in exactly the same way that
you are
and then to as we saw like with the
protests over the last couple of days
the black lives matter guys came out
they were then joined by extinction
rebellion with their bongo drums you
know everybody wants to come out and
sort of like join in with this kind of
um it's a it's just the thrill of being
in the
crowd and the carnival atmosphere of it
and and i think that
if you don't have those day-to-day
interactions with people that are
different from yourself either at work
or if you're religious you know like at
church or somewhere where you
you're able to come face to face with
people that
are not exactly like you without that
you're just going to be naturally bent
to an extreme
extreme position and i don't think
there's there's anything that can
sort of like get us back on kilter it's
also been very interesting the way it's
exposed
people's biases like you see people
going black lives matter fantastic
anti-lock down
disgusting women's vigil brilliant do
you see what i mean and it
it doesn't seem like people are
consistent anymore well i mean
anymore and i mean in relation to the i
mean there's been so much bus
positive for us about pretty patel's
moves to criminalize protest
essentially by you know saying that the
basis of
whether a protest can go ahead as if it
makes you know
a safe enough level of disruption noise
disruption
um i mean there was there was shock and
horror
i think rightly so at the way in which
women were treated by the police at the
vigil sarah everard's vigil
um on the weekend four people were
arrested at clapham common that night
in january 16 people were arrested in
clapham common on an anti-lockdown
protest
so abstractly if we the thing we're
horrified about
is police with their their kind of
elbows and their
knees on people's backs arresting them
on the base of the protest
it's been happening all year so yeah
this is the thing where i disagree with
you and maybe this comes back to our
little
discussion about biological determinism
what you call it
i don't think most people will ever be
comfortable with the
with with a picture of police officer
blokes
kneeling on women's backs it's just a
little well i just
tell you that an anti-lockdown talk
about coincidence at an anti-lockdown
protest
i don't know whether it was in january
but certainly previously in the year
there was a red-headed woman who looked
very much like patsy stevenson
um who i was punched pushed to the
ground by a police officer and
very violently arrested and it was yeah
but she had the wrong opinion
but this is what i'm talking about it's
you know it was the there have been i've
been on arrests about the student
movement when i was one of those people
that you know
went out a drop of a hat about you know
serious things like [ __ ]
at the time um you know there was there
were mass
arrests there were mass kettles there
was kind of you know and there was a
sense in which people
especially at that time students you
kind of wanted to be arrested
and there's this sort of does this spoil
in front of this question
push and pull which is there is this you
know
that people seem to be there has been a
chipping away at the right to protest
for a very long time
um for various reasons and you know but
from government but also people giving
in to the idea that you should have just
a one-day strike
with the nurses or trade unions rather
than cause disruption
but that that doesn't you know if we are
outraged because the cause we
like is the one that's being trampled on
by the police officer then you're doing
it wrong because actually you need to
support the right of
far-right people to protest you need to
support the right of climate
you know climate emergency protesters as
annoying as i find them
of of feminists of you know flat
earthers of whoever it is because the
this is like the issue of freedom of
speech which you guys have covered so
many times on this
um on trigonometry is that it isn't what
to call it
i was going to say podcast but i forget
that we're being filmed
it is an inalienable right that has no
ifs and no buts that you have to either
defend
for everyone yeah or you defend for no
one no i agree
you were talking about the far-right
flat earthers i'm like it's our audience
no an extinction rebellion we just had
the the co-founder on the show
but emma i i wanted to ask you because
you've done some great work on covering
the protests that followed the vigils
uh i'm assuming you weren't individuals
itself and
i wasn't at the first
and this is what i want to i mean it's
you you've changed my mind on that point
actually about
the the people not being comfortable
with women maybe it was the way it was
covered
or maybe well no i think you're right on
that it was particularly yeah
yeah uh but what did you make of all of
that
and and just how it happened how people
responded then the protest and you talk
about
other people coming along and jumping on
board just give us your thoughts on that
in the last five ten minutes yeah so i i
i wonder actually in relation to what
you were saying about
the footage of the women being nailed on
i think obviously that's
right quite shocking because of the like
gender dynamic and also because of what
happened to sarah everard
but i wonder whether that is partly to
do
with we almost seem to be sort of
obsessed with stories
um and telling ourselves stories at the
moment and that really played into what
happened at the protest so
i noticed that at the vigil from the
footage obviously i said i wasn't there
um the the footage of that and some of
the photographs showed
um some people with a cab or cops
bastards
signs and defund the police sign so they
they went to the vigil
with their placards in hand they already
had them clearly when they got there i'm
guessing they didn't just sort of
by the way sorry to interrupt is an
antifa slogan basically it is yeah and
um though there were also some
suggestions that there were some people
there in
in i identif identifiably
in black block the anti-fur black block
um
and so now the police have come out and
said that
i think it was 26 officers were
assaulted including
one female black officer who was
racially abused
um so maybe that vigil i've initially
came out
condemning the police's aggression
towards the women because i
don't think that vigil should have been
illegal in the first place i'm totally
in favor of the right to protest so i
don't think any heavy-handed
interaction with protesters is ever a
good thing
but maybe there was more into what was
going on
there than necessarily was initially
reported
and that really played out the next day
because people mobilized like that
um as soon as i arrived it was quite
clear that it had no longer had anything
to do with sarah everard
it was like the whole crowd was
absolutely strewn with these
akka or cop sebastian signs they were
shouting no justice no peace
the socialist worker was there um
the revolutionary communist group big
imperialism
banners it turned into a kind of like
far left rally that was a bit like blm
with a bit of women's rights sprinkled
into it
um and going back to my point about the
stories i think that
to some degree because of the the
natural resonance that that had for
people with what happened with george
floyd
the footage of the women being kneeled
on by the police the fact that
the person at the center of the
investigation is also a cop
that it played into the stories that
people were already obsessing about and
so
the mobilization of people coming out
with those signs
i don't know whether those people you
know were the same guys who came out to
protest in the black lives matter rally
or not but they had
um people who i presume with the
organizers
reading out um an assata shakuta poem
um which the the crowd was then
repeating back to them and assata shakur
is
from the black liberation army she's on
the fbi's most wanted
list for being convicted for killing a
cop and went on the run to cuba
um and so i don't think the crowd
necessarily realized that they were
basically echoing the words back maybe
even the police didn't realize it so
it was quite clear that um the protest
had been
hijacked by at least far-left
ideas whether or not the entire crowd
had turned up for that particular
reason i don't know um and then
obviously in the subsequent days you had
like the extinction rebellion guys
turned up and sister
sisters uncut which is a whole other
story um yeah
i mean i don't have much of a problem
with far left rallies i don't know i
i don't either when you said uh
revolutionary communist party
i mean the thing it's funny you know the
thing about these
as you're describing the protest well i
went to the one on sunday with my
uh my sign about freedom of protest
because that
as the days have gone on it's become
more about the about they're using the
slogan kill the bill
not the police as some people on twitter
haven't suggested but the
anti-and protest bill um but it is like
it's like a kind of everything but the
kitchen sink type protest where there
was
there was um uh speeches from people
about
uh the nurses strike which is you know
let's talk about it but
add a protest about sarah everard maybe
not there was um
one speaker talked about women muslim
women's access to resources
again you know the relation to sarah
brothers is very tenuous
tenuous there there were labour mps
getting up and grandstanding about
getting impressive
dick resigned i mean it's just it was
everything it was and there were people
holding placards saying we're
intersectional or we are nothing you're
like well this is a process about women
anyway the whole thing was
it was confused but i think and you know
in particular you mentioned the
swp um i mean the swp when i was at
university where
were broken apart by a rape scandal
because one of their their head
guys in the swp raped a woman and they
they
dealt with it in the kangaroo court
within the party and that's why
masses of people including my husband
left the swp in the
um in the sort of uh around 2014. so
when i saw their placards at this
particular protest i was like what the
[ __ ]
why are the swp here there is a bit of
an eye on rule with these things the
guys who bang on about women's rights
usually have something well
it was the same with the with the
sisters uncut they had a
a list of people that they said that
they'd like
were remembering or paying homage to in
some way and in that list were people
that had transitioned from
male into being female but before they
had transitioned
they had raped and murdered women
so yeah yeah it's a bit of a matter
no i i i i have been critical of sisters
and cut in the past but one thing they
did well at the protest that i was at
was that
um zara sultana the labour mp made a
massive grandstanding speech about
you know chris the dick and how evil she
was and this that and the other and then
sisters uncut got on the megaphone and
said
this is not an opportunity for labour
grandstanding
this is our protest this is not labors
and i was like yes because obviously
labour had
abstained on the police bill up until
now and so the whole
you know there's so much hypocrisy going
on there's so much opportunism going on
but the main question is
what are these protests trying to
achieve and and
you have to look at the in the same
breath they say
the streets should be free for women and
and they also then say
but we need to educate educate and
legislate
educate boys and decriminalize and
criminalize uh
misogyny and bring in new laws so there
is this is the central dichotomy of
everything we've been talking about
today
is that there is a toss-up between
women's safety and women's freedom and
the contemporary feminist movement has
gone down the route of women's safety
which means protection which means
restriction
which means denying all risk and what
we've lost
is the real f word not feminism uh which
is what i talk about in my book
but freedom which is freedom to as
camille paglia says and i quote it every
time i talk about this and we'll do
every time in the future
the freedom to risk rape the freedom to
risk danger
the freedom to do all the things that
men do with the
the kind of potential and the
understanding as an adult that those
things might come with the
with harm in the future for you but that
being free with all its
costs and all its consequences is always
going to be preferable to being
costed to being safe and the fact that
so many women
so many prominent professional you know
women
today can't see that and instead buy
into this
incredibly craven um whinging
middle-class crap that i think
contemporary feminism is
um that gets me so irate is depressing
and i think there are many many many
many many more women out there who are
watching this thinking
what in the hell are they going on about
amen and a women
women well done mate yes
a women indeed guys we've run out of
time unfortunately thank you so much for
coming on i'm sure this issue will
is something we'll we'll continue
talking about but in the meantime we've
got one more question for you
which is what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society but we really
should be we'll start with you ella
my bug bear at the moment is uh ltns
which you think might think are a very
specific
um local issue traffic neighborhoods
mainly because my life in hackney has
been made a misery because of
and i love driving around in my little
white van and shocking people
particularly if i'm wearing lipstick in
the van
but i can't do that anymore because of
ltns but actually the reason why it's
interesting people should talk about it
not just because it's being rolled out
across the country because the central
question of low traffic neighborhoods
is what we've been sort of talking about
this evening is who gets to decide on
political decisions do
is there is the climate emergency as
people call it reason enough to make
people's
ordinary working class often people's
lives of misery in their own
neighborhoods
who gets to decide who owns our streets
is it the councillors
who don't give really a figure out about
local residents
or is it the residents themselves so um
you know if you're interested in
democracy if you're interested in
environmentalism and all that kind of
thing look up low traffic neighborhoods
and look up right where they're
happening it's not just in hybrid
hackney
it's across the country and it's really
pissing me off
[Laughter]
well if you will permit me to be very
predictable
um i think uh the thing that people are
talking about but not as much as they
should be
is nchr's non-crime hate incidents um
so recently harry miller is obviously
going through the court of appeal at the
moment
um trying to get non-crime hate
incidents removed from the guidance of
the college of policing
and so really i think the thing that we
should all be talking about
is these unaccountable quangos who seem
to be making a kind of
um parallel law for us all um
particularly in relation to free speech
so the um college of policing created
these
nchis wasn't something that was passed
as a law
through parliament and so i think that
is the thing that we should all be
talking about because
there are unaccountable quangos that are
surpassing
the uh proper parliamentary scrutiny in
the
legal system as it should be and they
have no democratic accountability so
that's what we should all be talking
about there's quite a bit of that going
all around isn't there parliamentary
scrutiny and all the rest of it
ella whelan emma webb thank you so much
for coming on and thank you for watching
at home we will see you very soon with
another brilliant episode like this one
or a live stream
and they all go out at 7 p.m uk time
take care guys and see you soon
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below